I've been on a lot of shows but there's
no better crowd than just right here I
Pro you came out here you lit this crowd
out I'm just telling the truth
your truth teller you got your you got
your book oh yeah yeah let me read some
of it you don't have to do you know you
don't have to do that that's rich yeah
what's up pal this is not a memoir it
says my memoir on it oh yeah well I
thought this was a memoir it does not
only says a memoir on it but it's a
novel I don't know so I'm you know I was
angry when it was in the fiction and
nonfiction yeah good nice about memoirs
is a memoir doesn't mean anything right
it's like if you you know about Grapes
of Wrath you like hey there's no grapes
yeah or you put in the grape section
that's yeah Mart yeah
then everybody will find grapes of
wrath' yeah
people that like grapes okay listen no
one set it down you made your point
I think this was a memory if this were a
memoir yeah I would put juicy things
from my own life right right like what
kind of things would you put in there
that nobody knows well I guess the
biggest thing that nobody knows about me
is I'm a deeply closeted gay man wait
I mean that's I mean that's you're a gay
man
I'm not gay I said I'm deeply closeted
train is an arrow so you're a gay man
who won't admit it no no do you know a
deeply closeted means yeah it means a
man who will not acknowledge that he's
gay
yes so I'm telling ya I'm not gay I got
a wife I just got a wife I just got
married because I thought go through
that charade keep appearances up oh yeah
that's the thing you tell ya this were a
man mm right if this were a memoir I
would tell about my wife what a
battle-axe relax I mean no one's called
their wife a battle-axe since nineteen
for s five president god how do you feel
about a woman she's supposed to be my
life partner I look in the mirror the
other day and I says to her I says honey
I look in the mirror and all I see is a
fat ugly old man and I need you to give
me a compliment she says all right then
your eyesight is damn near perfect I
said you dirty dog we have fights
constantly look you do do you know and
sometimes it bleeds over like we were
driving a car we went past a bunch of
animals there was a pig a cow I know I
admit this is a little crew you're kind
of mad at this doesn't matter so I say
he said Pig that cow you know horse the
remind you of any relatives she says
yeah my in-laws I said you're dirty
Wow dirty dog again
Wow night until I met my wife I always
felt incomplete now I'm finished
[Laughter]
1935 radio show wanna take a break for
justice you'll figure that let me say
something more modern and stylish then
okay my wife went into a coma
oh sorry to hear that and the doctor
said to me and you won't hear this for
many 19:35 comet he says to me there's
one way to wake her up but it's a little
unconventional you go in there and you
have oral sex with her I said by God he
says I've seen it work I said well I'm
willing to try so I go in there I'm in
there about five minutes and I come out
I said doc she's choking
[Applause]
but that's modern medicine medicine
we're gonna take a break I'm gonna find
out what's happening here we're gonna
take a little break here here's a
message from the good people at boss
cold chocolate syrup MacDonald after
this
you